fröde solle wie ihr seht stehe ich nicht
von meiner weißen wand und das hier ist
auch nicht das geplante video zu
machiavellis muss für alle die es
verpasst haben wir machen hier auf dem
kanal eine kleine serie zur dunklen
triade dem druck dem bösen eigenschaften
die allenfalls innewohnen sollen
teil eins zu nazismus kam vor zwei
wochen und kam ziemlich gut bei euch an
die dunklen seelen rechtecks gewählt er
wollte wissen wann es weitergeht mit
machiavellis muss und ich sagte heute
leider ist melanie unsere tolle liebe
grafikerin krank und sie haben das video
das finde ich ganz fertig bekommen
heute ist nicht mein tag bzw
es ist nicht unsere woche ich habe hier
nämlich gerade die sound machine
rausgeholt und wollte hier so ein
gleiches an dieser stelle ein spielen
aber an scheiße ist die batterie leer
und ich habe keine neuen jedenfalls das
ist der nachteil vor einem kleinen team
ist bei einerseits schnellen flexibel
aber wenn mal einer von zweien ausfällt
dann helfe diese fälle aber dass die
zeit doch mal um etwas zu tun was ich
schon länger mal tun wollte nämlich
kommentare kommentieren
und jetzt würde ich so ein yeah applaus
naja ok sam oder scham hat einen tipp
gegenüber fressen und zwar vielleicht
mal gurke und möhre zum snacken
schnibbeln und das machen
gurken und möhren waschen und mürrisch
der chips ich glaube du hast du was
falsch verstanden ich glaube es
funktioniert nicht anbieter schreibt
jede meile kannst du mir bitte verraten
wo du deine klamotten kauft lieber alle
das würde ich gerne aber ich kann nicht
weil wir sind hier bei funk und das wäre
wäre aber wenn ich irgendwann mal ganz
groß werde
dann lasse ich alles stehen und liegen
und mache nur noch höher sein aber wenn
ich mal der secret of scientists wieder
betriebe was ich zumindest vorhaben im
nächsten monaten wenn ich einen
hoffentlich ein bisschen mehr zeit habe
werde ich ja dort früher oder später
auch dieselben klamotten anziehen dann
kannst du mich da noch mal fragen
apropos dieselben romans die möchte
wissen was der unterschied zwischen das
gleiche und dasselbe ist ganz einfach
wir beide die gleichen chips essen
bedeutet das wir essen so champs
derselben sorte marke aber wenn wir die
seelen chips essen dann müsstest du
schon her kommen mit mir die chips essen
bzw eigentlich wenn man es ganz genau
nehmen würde müsste einer die chips
essen sie erbrechen und der andere will
julia 7 schreibt zum erkältungs video
nicht vergessen in die hand zu husten
und niesen erkältungszeit ist zwar
vorbei hoffentlich aber bitte nicht in
die hand husten oder niesen sondern in
den ellenbogen hände sind natürlich die
allerbeste ihren verteiler ziehen sollte
man auch niemals ellenbogen lecken das
betrifft nicht nur die eigenen stuttgart
stuttgart muss die muskatnuss
wieso hast du nicht mehr abonnenten du
bist großartig
wir liegen dank ich jetzt arbeite ich
fahre ich wählen
hallo wie geht's dir du ich nehme gerade
das video auf dachte vielleicht willst
du auch dabei sein
wir fragten mich jemand wie sowie nicht
mehr abonnenten haben
falls jemand von euch da draußen uns
gerne
gut aber einfach zu fahrlässig einen
account zu machen um zu abonnieren ich
kann es nur empfehlen können helden
beschreibt zu dem video warum fakten zu
den fans wieder warum fakten und rehbein
um mich beeinflussen
ich wäre nie auf meiner meinung niemals
und ich lass mir doch nichts anderes
sagen letzte spirit trainer fragt ob ich
schon mal zufällig bei einem science
slam mitgemacht haben zufällig schaden
hier diejenigen die das nicht kennen 11
lahm ist so was wie ein poetry slam nur
mit forschungsstadt mit poesie und parma
mit gemacht in den letzten jahren
letzter zeit nicht mehr allzu oft war
ich nicht mehr allzu viel zeit habe aber
wenn ihr mich mal auf der bühne in
action sehen wollt verlinke ich euch 11
der von ihr und infobox sohn mcallister
fragt ob ich jetzt hier auch bei schön
schlau aufhöre
das bezog sich darauf dass ich bei auf
klo aufgehört habe auf no ist ein talk
format für 13 bis 17 jährige mädels und
alle anderen die sich gerne anhören was
zwei mädels offen klo zu bereden haben
klingt komisch ist aber ganz gut auf flo
gehört auch zum funk kosmos schaut da
mal gerne vorbei wie gesagt ich musste
auch für reiche leider keine zeit mehr
habe und ich vielleicht manche wissen
bin ich ziemlich bis sie war ich mach
mich nur schön schlau
das ist mein haupt ding aber wie ich
schon gesagt habe ich eigentlich um
einen eigenen kanal auf dem ich gerne
mal wieder was machen würde für den ich
keine zeit hatte
dann bin ich bei terek / und chor neues
mitglied des kurs und ich bin jetzt bei
einem neuen funk format dabei und zwar
weil musst du wissen musst du wissen ist
wenn man so will eine art
nachrichtenformate die fächer deutsch
geschichte und chemie
das wenig sind diese woche online
gegangen und physik und mathe folgen
noch
[Musik]
der stolze vater ist schreibt zu warum
wir auffällt muss reinfallen
an und für sich ein gutes video schaden
wird dass du zu funk gehört die mag ich
nämlich überhaupt nicht weil sie viel
sjb bullshit produziert sj sj saure
joghurt wurst statistisches jugend
wetter soziale jahres wohlfahrt sozialen
jahres und war gar nicht so weit weg
social justice war okay wie geschafft
hat vorerst eine woche meinen koffer
entdeckt im science of music video darf
ich auch mal ganz kurz betonen wie knut
wie eigentlich bei papa ist dass ich
glaube die einlage ist am ende so ein
bisschen untergegangen weil ich glaube
nicht so viele leute die end karte
schauen deswegen hier nochmal bitte
schön
[Musik]
wusstet ihr außerdem dass mein papa auch
chemiker ist ohne ihn wäre ich niemals
chemikerin geworden ich bin eher sollte
öfters mal drei videos vorbeischauen
oder dabei sein ich weiß noch nicht ob
ich ihn überzeugen kann
wenn ihr auch dafür sind recht gesunden
bereit er weg mehr sagt ich spreche
gehirn lustig aus die hirten heißt nicht
gehirn was auf hochdeutsch vielleicht
gehört sowie 14 soll ich auch als
letztes gelernt dass nicht viel zusammen
14 als weltweit schreibt in die
kommentare hier richtig ausspricht wenn
ihr lust habt können wir so was hier ab
und an mal machen natürlich nicht
anstelle des regulären videos dass es
heute wie gesagt krankheitsbedingt
krankheitsbedingt eine ausnahme wenn ihr
bock habt sie bescheid können wir gerne
noch mal machen und nächste woche gibt
wenn wirklich machiavellis muss die
dunklen cd neuer warten hat ein ende
also bis dann und bleibt sicher